our video today is for all the Riverdale
fans out there I hope you're all
enjoying season 3 but let's throw it
back to when things weren't quite as
weird
so continues our nerdiest mystery yet
hey everybody it's your host Noor and
welcome back to the things before we get
started I'm gonna need you to subscribe
to our things family and give this video
a big thumbs up to let me know that
you're a Riverdale fan so Archie comic
fans totally freaked out back when they
announced a first season of Riverdale
Michelle we know and love today has
strayed far away from the original
comical theme for starters we've got our
main characters Archie Jack head Betty
and Veronica you need us there is no
denying that all the characters are
played by some gorgeous people but
that's not what the comics had in mind
for Archie or Jughead in the comics
Archie is anything but a heart thrown
he's displayed as a sweet and quirky
redhead unlike on screen Archie played
by New Zealand actor KJ app'
the comic book Archie was anything but
mysterious deep and brooding KJ is
missing most staple comic book freckles
and is not a redhead either no matter
how well he plays without my ice for
joke ed it's pretty clear that Cole
plays a more modern version of the
character with his crown brilliantly
being replaced by a crown inspired
beanie his nose is also a lot less
comical Veronica Lodge is also a
character that is pretty different from
her comic South she is still a posh and
rich character in love with Archie
except this I'm not your typical mean
girl I'm despite her original character
being a white female in the original
comics on screen Veronica is a proud
latina who pees a ton of Hammacher
heritage something we are totally here
for as for Betty Cooper her and family
are shown as the average
all-american family back in the comic
instead of a sweetened DC Betty Cooper
Marvel shows us an entirely different
and more complex side to this character
everyone
the farm knows all of your dirty secrets
aside from her totally bizarre family
dynamics there is a much darker side to
Betty Cooper than we ever could have
imagined before what was the family like
hers who can blame her on the show
Betty and her family are related to
another twisted family the blossoms
this makes Betty the cousin of a fierce
and fabulous Gerald Lhasa this family
relation was never mentioned in the
comics and when there was the death of
her brother Jason while Cheryl does
share a lot of her personality with her
comic book character Lauren Riverdale
she is not fighting for Archie's
attention at all despite that awkward
one-time kids what are you doing she is
actually a lot more attracted to serpent
gang member tawny topaz played by
Vanessa Morgan who is her real-life
Betsy according to Tony's character
description on the official Archie comic
web site she is a tough girl who sports
pink hair and is always wearing a purple
jumpsuit in both versions her character
is strong confident and even bisexual on
screen we see Tony show a brief interest
in Jughead all he and Betty were broken
up before finally getting together with
Cheryl now let's talk about bromance duo
fangs Fogerty and sweet pea in the
comics fangs is actually the leader of
the Southside serpents and is spotted in
the little Archie edition many fans have
been so quick to point out his good
looks in the show but check him out in
the comic books fun fact for you guys in
the comics fangs has a girlfriend and
her name is penny Peabody can we talk
about a whole life glow up who here
remembers Sweet Pea from the comics
anything nobody well good because that
was a trick question Sweet Pea was never
found in the comics well at least not
under that name some fans have even
theorized that he might be the love
child of penny and f:p Jones one issue
with this theory is that it
doubtful that the writers of the show
would make FP Jones the mystery father
yet again I want to know what you guys
think so be sure to let me know your
theories down in the comments in one of
the episodes of season three we got a
look into the high school lives of all
the Riverdale parents and one point we
even got to see a throwback aesthetic of
Archie and the game Riverdale is not the
problem me I want to stay here my whole
life one of the things we haven't got to
see is a look into the world of little
Archie seeing a mini version of all of
our favorite cast members would be
amazing so let's just hope that the
creative directors have this in mind the
comics also gave readers a bunch of
awesome comic crossovers including one
with another fan favorite the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and finally let's
talk about the short-lived Josie and the
Pussycats
unlike the comics so she'll introduce a
lot more diversity with every member of
the Pussycats being a beautiful woman of
color speaking of the ladies I'm pretty
sure I am not the only one who wants to
see them back in action and more
involved in the Riverdale storyline if
you guys agree be sure to leave a cat
emoji after all your comments and you've
now reached the end of our video be sure
to subscribe to our things family for
more videos like this one and hit me up
on social media at normal view see you
guys next time
[Music]